[Music]
nice try submitted by Kiera a pornstar
claims a fans lawsuit is just a creepy
attempt to meet I bet you that is true
nice try buddy
that's pretty genius though throughout
you sue your favorite person just so you
have to be in court with them for that
long yeah and you put on the moves in
court I'm suing you right now like
what's the move there this middle-aged
uber driver how did you meet with each
other I sued her got each other yeah
could we suit each if we're gonna same
rumors she'll just know it's la yes this
dude his name is James and he is saying
that he was scammed out of $1,800 by
someone claiming to be this porn star
who was stranded in Ghana and so this
porn star her name is Danny Daniels
that's her stage name for her real name
is Cara Lee or sug so she looks like he
sounds familiar
I wonder why never heard her name in my
entire life or Nikki raised my right
hand to Jesus Christ Bible by the Bible
the Bible is a he wrote 28 years old he
penned Danny is countersuing because
she's saying that this is all some
[ __ ] ass attempt for him to meet her
because he just follows a whole bunch of
other girls on social media that are
similar to her also a big red flag was
the fact that he used her stage name
instead of just to confirm he said that
she stole 880 no there's been this scam
going on where her husband said that a
lot of people have been using her name
to pretend to be her and she's stranded
in Ghana and that she needs money from
these people well why would he sue what
so then is he
saying like you stole my money but it
was someone oh okay that makes sense got
it I was and what he's looking for is
charity is like her to feel bad and it's
kind of like a make-a-wish Foundation
but for porn no I'm here to feel bad
he's like trying to get her to pay the
money he was scammed out of but then
it's also for her what I'm saying is
okay so imagine you're in this desperate
guys shoes right okay so you have this
idea of okay well [ __ ] well I got duped
but maybe maybe the real one would feel
bad and actually come meet me right
that's that's what I'm saying so it's
like a fake it's like a porn star makeup
they know is that he thought she was in
Ghana and he's like oh if I give her
money she's gonna [ __ ] me
yes I just know she will yes that's the
this has happened so frequently to hurt
that she's had to post on her verified
accounts like I'm not like a place you
may be trapped in you know whoever is
the scammer in this whole situation
that's just the same thing that they're
using in it apparently it's working
because this dude gave like almost two
thousand dollars I would imagine it's
always the porn star community that has
like the most loyal people that actually
takes my money yeah hell yeah right yeah
to help you right and so they're just
like oh yeah it's my favorite person
that I love to watch naked fine
I'll clear out my savings and ask for
more people for that money I just makes
sense for the no [ __ ] good yeah and
they exist they're real yeah real people
there are porn addicts out there they're
walking this earth actually like I'm a
confession today yeah it's a 17-point
membership some of people that that fall
for the scams like the [ __ ] Ethiopian
print scams or whatever yeah like how do
I keep happening people are greedy
what is that help I don't know it's like
the Nigerian Nigerian prince scam people
I think they finally got their big break
in life that [ __ ] exists this has
existed since like the eighties so like
you would get this like an old-school
male but the way that it works is some
banker goes oh like you're actually an
heir
oh I dunno I used to get emails like
that - yeah and then basically you go
all you got to do is deposit ten
thousand dollars and then we'll send you
a million the ones that I would get were
like just give us your routing number
and your home address and your checking
account number and the money that'll be
transferred into your account yeah I
recently actually just had there was an
account and like I'm sure we all have
like different accounts that just like
use your pictures and stuff like that
but I recently had somebody that was
using my pictures and asking people for
money
and that's like normally I just
disregard those accounts but somebody
sent me screenshots because they're like
oh I saw you post this account I want to
see what they're saying and they were
just like oh I you know like I'm running
on tough times right now do you think
you could just send me like 200 bucks on
been lowered you know and if you do that
with like 200 people and that's a that's
like some money right there and so I was
like this is [ __ ] and that's when I
had to say something because that's
total manipulation and they actually
think that they're building this
relationship with somebody that's not
they are yeah they want the money for
you right that's like when people are
still in your videos and you take their
adsense it's like [ __ ] you back no one I
think I just said like don't talk to
them and then I report at the account
and getting deleted did you feel like oh
my god if only I did this myself I would
have got rich no it honestly was like it
it really upset me like I it really
bothered me to know that somebody was
just like using my photos to get money
for themself it was just twisted I would
be so honored did someone I would be
honored I don't think my face would work
no I mean you should be honored okay
fine I'm honored thank you please make
all the fake accounts no please don't do
that please
I mean 200 bucks from a stranger not bad
not bad dude absolutely do be able to
meet them or give him a blow job or
anything I've seen what the person
looked like to feel it cuz the guy got
him to admit it was like a guy Turkey
Donna Donna yeah whose traffic yeah
it was weird dads are the Stooges
revealed is all identity mm-hmm I can
actually I'll show you guys after
yes ting so there's a lot of lonely ass
dudes out there that are willing to pay
anything for attention
yes what do you think all those ads are
it's like meet hot singles night who a
day for women
no no but for one type of person only
therefore the lonely guy and also don't
like those sex lines still exist or you
can call and like have phone sex
absolutely those guys that are doing
this if you watch Comedy Central after
10:00 p.m. you can see this really yeah
it's always a girl in front of a
fireplace always yeah to get real person
how personal so my dad left and job in
three years have a son and she's I got
can you can you just jack off and like
let me mold or something like [ __ ] let
me move I think that least tell me about
your feet or something yeah cool I liked
in that example you guys [ __ ] was
switched up the characters yeah yeah I
thought you were being the girlfriend
the girl at the end the girl she's like
oh my god like can you just stop
complaining and let me know cause I
thought you meant like the girl was yeah
that's what I thought he was doing funny
though know if you want to get personal
and then the girl starts complaining
like Joe non-sequiturs his own tangent
which I love was the Jacob feel skit
that you guys may be what was it I
forgot Humbert but just know it was like
some sort of life no that's something
else yeah I was another one I was
probably inspired by that but I forgot
what it was no you won't talk yeah
there's my dear long are they yeah Wow
mine are long if you notice
you view mascara that make them yeah I
don't need mascara to make them longer
I've had many makeup ladies here to me
every counter every single lady is a
makeup lady okay cuz we all wear makeup
no real makeup ladies on movie sets oh
this guy's a hotshot thank you very much
Steve's character and his movie funny
story it's the best I didn't get to see
that movie I play a centaur spoiler you
do shut up really actually cast a cast a
horse for my Bob from mybama that's
legit we like looking through this it's
like which horse his owners like oh we
got it
Wilbur we got it on Wilbur you still got
it Wilbur yeah chestnut
that's crazy cuz even horses go into
porn what else is the old racehorse
gonna do when they can't race anymore
he's got me it's bill somehow yeah they
gotta [ __ ] weird dudes for money shape
or girls - I want to be sexist I was
looking for horses to buy and relatable
again so it couldn't go anywhere from
free to like like a car oh it's a couple
thousand dollars so buying the half of
the horse isn't the expensive part
keeping keeping the horse is the
expensive part like feeding them and all
that late a lot it's labor - it's very
labor intensive because you gotta walk
them and move them and if you can't just
leave them in their box and yeah and
then they you've got a brush and all
that but I mean their food being a
staple and all that - you got it for the
horse there's a lot of resources because
like after a certain age you can't ride
them anymore because like they're so
like and I was looking at it like damn
what's the point it's free you can't
even ride up it was economically for you
they don't know what to do they'll just
be like here dude it's like my cat I'm
like dude how much is [ __ ] kitty
litter it's so goddamn expensive for
King litter and for cat food and all
[ __ ] especially if you get like economic
thing dude the cats do but then I'm like
oh they're in a lot of why they makes it
me so it's not a bad job if they're porn
stars you know what I mean you see I did
that well you know like I mean well I
one time I saw this porn I said a
million times it was like a guy and a
girl in a horse table and I thought the
guy and the girl were gonna do it
but then the girl pulls out the horses
that it can start sucking it and he
starts [ __ ] her from the back yeah
and I was like well the video damn damn
damn damn so he got the horses it's
money to get these big stock baby how do
you like Michigan like you legal or some
[ __ ] it's that's a myth it's not illegal
that's an urban legend if it's very it's
actually very yeah it's not the same as
I know in some states and not in illegal
in some not States like you can do it's
not my child porn because these horses
are over the age of 18 in backwards
parts of the country but in the more
forward-thinking areas completely and
very least I'm asking seriously like
just no issue in some places it is
completely allowed yeah to search no no
- I'm talking about surging but you can
marry and [ __ ] animals you're still not
answering her question I need to know
when I go to prison if I'm trying to
search for this oh whoa actively search
you can google it for each person oh you
had to actively saw something for that
that wasn't just on the tree like when
you pop up board and then you just see a
guy and a girl like she's in a [ __ ]
horse riding outfit and then during a
stable I'm like this might be nice and
you click it and then
yeah and they're like what's up I've
done this tons of times like I've done
one works like a guy and a girl and then
like and then and then the guys go out
and then she has a wiener and he starts
sucking on it and I'm like I should have
scrolled through with you I've seen the
one with a girl I seen the one with a
guy on the girl they're in a stable
she's wearing jodhpurs and a helmet and
then he's like he's like you want to
[ __ ] and she's like absolutely and then
he takes his dick around she's like
sorry but I need real dick and then she
gets the horse oh it's a classic
American one it sound like the same one
totally wait that's a Kentucky gray yeah
[Music]
[Music]